[Applause]  yes  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  ah  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  thank you  [Applause]  [Applause]  what a shot  oh  well that was okay y'all  yes  oh double shot  help us out and hit subscribe  oh come on  you have time  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  now you found  [Applause]  oh  [Applause]  good job now  well thank you  oh  [Applause]  foreign  [Applause]  oh  oh  [Applause]  oh  hahaha  [Music]  [Applause]  sorry  can you handle the swaying easily  hmm  [Applause]  get back oh  [Music]  yes  [Applause]  hahaha  [Music]  [Applause]  oh no  [Applause]  there's still 73 of you guys watching  who haven't subscribed so remember to do  that now  and if you haven't seen our web store  yet go and check out pongfinity.store  we've got some cool  table tennis products until next time